permettre une prise de conscience avec
sa semaine du handicap la ville de
montigny le bretonneux sensibilise
depuis 17 ans à tous les handicaps
moteurs mentaux ou encore psychique
permettre une forme d'inclusion à long
terme on va le travail encore
extrêmement long et normand ou poursuit
on poursuit la démarche et on espère que
sur le long terme et chausseront leurs
preuves et des ateliers pour les
scolaires et les enfants mais aussi une
mise en avant du sport adapté
cette semaine c'est aussi l'occasion du
12e tournoi de hand fauteuil on a
quatre équipes en tout avec des équipes
vraiment de très très bon niveau
donc on à caen qui est venue jouer des
tours
nous avons vernon et l'équipe de
montigny avec le co vide on est déjà
enchanté d'avoir pu maintenir le tournoi
compte tenu des difficultés que peuvent
avoir certaines régions une 17e édition
qui avait choisi de prendre de la
hauteur avec la grimpe adapté encadrés
par l'association ciel on a ouvert cette
section parce que l'on s'est rendu
compte que l'autisme l escalade
faisaient vraiment bon ménage
moi ça fait dix ans que jean cadre de
l'escale adapté dans mon île m avec ma
compagne notamment et on a eu des
résultats assez surprenants dans les
championnats de france qu'on a eu deux
champions de france juniors et un senior
alors qu'on avait fait aucune
compétition avant est modifié à cause de
l'épidémie de kovy de 19 la semaine
s'est conclue par un challenge en 10
grimpe et un triathlon au centre sportif
pierre de coubertin